how did I go from wanting to become a
wrestler to becoming a successful
YouTuber I'll try to keep it short but
it's kind of sad too so when wrestling
didn't pan out I just cost the nearest
branch and just hopped into a factory
where my dad had been working for 30
years so he was able to get me a job
there the vetting process for that was
like a year so I was like a year on my
own doing nothing and when I eventually
got into the job in question I won't say
where I'm working I just was miserable
the people who were there working
alongside me weren't the happiest of
people and it sort of rubbed off on me
and I was just in a negative spot the
contract that I had signed was for about
a year and when it was coming up to the
end of that I just started thinking
about okay what am I going to do I want
to become an animator that was what I
had in my head and so I had been reading
loads of books and textbooks of like
classes and courses that I could be
taking and I was sort of teaching myself
as well in the meantime how to animate
but I also started picking up Dragon
Ball again and I thought oh you know my
friends over in Japan right now and I
thought okay a cool way for me to kind
of like stay in touch with him would be
to like make a video on Dragon Ball and
so I made a video on Dragon Ball and I
sent it over to him he thought it was
funny